the damage is hard to miss hundreds of
Israeli settlers destroying Palestinian
homes after two Israelis were shot dead
been seeing cars that have been taught
so far I've counted about 30 or 40 of
them and that's only on just this small
stretch
Muhammad Ade shows us the damage to his
car parts business he says it will take
him years to recover the hundreds of
thousands of dollars he's now lost
no one came to protect me or my family
we couldn't protect our shops the
Israeli Army wouldn't let us they fired
us
nine-year-old lilas was studying when
the settlers turned up she ran up to the
rooftop she says because she was scared
they'd break into her home
her grandfather Maharaj the medi who's
lived in Hawaii since 1964 says the
situation is getting worse
every week settlers attacked us and
broke our Windows last year then an aid
agency installed this metal fencing it's
our only protection but it's like prison
hawana is one of several Palestinian
towns surrounded by allele Israeli
settlements with a big military base
nearby just a few hours after the
attacks and hawara is an absolute Ghost
Town the only ones we're seeing here are
Israeli soldiers that are patrolling
this street as well as media People Like
Us that have come to cover this story
but the locals living here are hiding in
their homes they said for fear that the
settlers will come back and burn their
property
Israel's defense minister has ordered
his forces to prepare for an escalation
of violence
by reinforcing activities on the ground
additional forces protective components
of settlements and roadways and the most
important to get to the terrorists and
bring them to justice either to court or
to the cemetery
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has called on settlers to not
take the law into their own hands but
Palestinians say the law only protects
Israelis and there's no accountability
for settler attacks
Al Jazeera hawara in occupied West Bank